controversial issue a lot of
conservative backbenchers don't like the
idea
of vaccine passports some on grounds of
ethics and the smp and labour party have
been commenting
today too certainly the smp and labour
are skeptical ian blackford who's a
westminster leader of the scottish
nationalists has tweeted this in the
last
hour or so the uk government hasn't
published any firm proposals on covet
certificates
and the tory position has been mired in
confusion and contradiction
on the basis of information available
smp mps would not
support tory plans due to serious
concerns
over ethics now i've spoken to mr
blackford uh in the last hour actually
he's quite busy uh
in his home on sky with lambing season
with lambs being born but he did tell me
that
he was very very skeptical in particular
about people needing
vaccine passports to get into the inside
of pubs
and restaurants so the s p with a
similar position to labor
but remember when we get the full
details which we have not had yet
that position could change mr blackford
also telling me he wants the uk
government to work with devolved
administrations like the scottish wealth
and northern irish governments to try
and work together perhaps he's
suggesting
a sort of uk policy as opposed to having
different policies in different parts of
the uk
kia stammer visiting plymouth today
didn't have a particularly
different opinion this is what he had to
say i don't think the government knows
what its plan is
um you know one day it's to cover pubs
the next day
it's not one day it's a vaccine passport
the next day it's a certificate
one day it's a certificate the next day
it's a it's it's a test
so we've seen this before with track
trace and isolate
grand plans that don't deliver cost a
fortune
and very often land with contracts to
friends and colleagues of the
conservative party we've seen too much
of that cronyism
so we do not support these plans in
their current form
so both the labour and smp leaders at
westminster suggesting today they'll
vote against
the government if they do bring such a
plan but of course we have not
seen the details of the plan the
government have not set out how a
vaccine passport system would work
domestically and therefore kimberley i
think both the smp
and labor have the wiggle room to change
their minds and effectively
back the government if the new plans are
put forward and the proposals aren't
necessarily
as significant as some reports have so
far suggested